I think someone got caught having sex
once in the back bathroom we're just
kind of wild was that bad no the
grossest thing I've ever seen in a
fitting room a dirty condom someone
changed their kid in the dressing room
rather than going to the bathroom to do
it but they just left it in the dressing
room for us Thanks I once saw a man pick
his nose and definitely clean it on one
of our jackets I was like ill ill ill I
haven't ever caught customers hooking up
but I did catch a coming-out story a
younger girl actually came out to her
mom while in the dressing room because
her mom walked in on her and her
girlfriend kissing it was basically like
an episode of Jerry Springer played out
in the dressing room it was amazing so I
had this woman who I helped find her
perfect bag and at the end of it she
looked at me and she said you know what
I've always wanted to do is she hit me
across the side of my face she was very
happy with the purse when customers
asked you to look for things in the back
it could go one or two ways so you can
actually go to the back and put in an
earnest effort I've been to the fact
like a hundred million times I already
know we don't have it but most times
honestly what associated to do is go in
the back and I just stand there I just
stand in the back and then they just go
back out and like yeah we don't have it
I'm so sorry and I wasn't the only one
who did this by the way I've definitely
witnessed people stealing things from
the store baby strollers are the number
one thing where if you see them and
there's no baby inside chances are there
are gonna be people trying to steal I
think the craziest thing that I've ever
seen somebody do as far as silly has
been to literally walk in the store just
do like that and just walk right out of
this store and we literally had to just
watch it happen so they bought a box
Oreos
hey all three rows of Oreos brought them
back return them and said that they
tasted weird and they gave her a full
refund
like how could you eat the whole box and
be like nah and then bring him in like
that's ridiculous the craziest thing
I've experienced working retail is
taking back a pair of five-year-old
clearly used panties and although it was
five years old she was technically well
within her rights to return those
underwear so this woman returned used
panties the only real way to get a good
price or know when something is really
on sale is if you've actually been
following the price for a while
typically around holiday season or any
like big-boob season they'll raise the
prices up just a little bit just add
like five or ten dollars whatever you
think looks good so that people can see
that the price actually dropped or if
they do actually give you a discount
it'll be attached to another item like
another seasonal item that you'll
probably buy statistically because
you're buying that one item so if you
think you're actually getting a great
deal chances are you're not but if you
feel like you're getting a discount
that's what counts
any time around the holidays was always
super stressful more stressful than it
needs to be because you're literally
just coming in there to buy something
give us your money and leave it seems
like whenever anybody walks through the
door
politeness and any kind of sensibility
towards human interaction and being nice
was just out the [ __ ] window just be
nice to the people that are working for
you if it's not going the way you want
it to go chances are that's just theirs
out of their power I think people kind
of fail to realize that these are people
too that are actually working in this
arena just remember those things when
we're out doing any holiday shopping
these people retail people are human too
[Music]